find her inspiration do that never stop
until the day you die hi I'm Ted baliker
with reason TV and today I'll be sitting
down the filmmaker Roger Nygaard Nygaard
has all kinds of directing and editing
credits under his belt and he's the
director of the new documentary the
nature of existence tell me in a
nutshell what your documentary is about
well it's all the answers to all the
mysteries of human existence in one
movie I literally traveled the world I
went to five continents talked to 170
people from experts to my neighbor's
daughter and the entire spectrum in
between what are some of the favorite
questions well I started with the big
one which is why do we exist that's the
main one the number-one question it's
the age-old existentialist question but
that opens up the door to a lot more
questions like well as long as we are
here what do we do about it what is our
purpose and how do we better get along
how can we better coexist with each
other
a lot of people go in a religious
direction when you ask them why do we
exist they talk about to glorify God to
know God to be with God etc and so that
begs the question what is or who is God
to find God for me and you find a lot of
different definitions from people I
think Gandhi said there are as many
religions on the planet as there are
people have you were there any
interesting patterns that you saw across
some of the big questions well if you
add up the number of religions currently
practiced on the planet there's over a
thousand so that number tells you
something right there what's the
smallest religion there are some really
offbeat ones like the Raelians who
believe in that there's an alien race
that brought us here which is not so
different from the Scientologists
there's one that I went to I went to a
celebration called omerta the-- which is
where the they're called Baba lovers
because they followed my hair Baba I'm a
hair Baba means compassionate father
he's a guru and he's got about maybe
it's hard to gauge but maybe fifty
thousand followers he directed Trekkies
as well which is celebrated for
quirky characters who are the new
Nygaard characters that are coming out
this time
well that's the thing is it's the topic
is less important in a good documentary
than finding interesting people to talk
about the topic there's a guru named aha
for instance who you've probably never
seen anything like him he's he is he's
the type of person people go to and ask
questions and he answers questions he's
it looks a little bit like Harry Knowles
of a Nakul nose you know so he's got a
unique look but you wouldn't necessarily
expect him to be you know mr. wisdom but
when you listen to what he says what he
says is really interesting and usually
pretty down-to-earth so you must be a
much wiser man now than you were at the
beginning of this you mentioned advice
what kind of pearls of wisdom can you
toss our way I changed me dramatically
actually I mean imagine talking to a
hundred and you know fifteen hundred
seventy people many of which were
psychologists spending two hours with a
psychologist asking him the toughest
questions that are keeping you up at
night all for free we all search for
happiness that's one thing people say I
just want to be happy I want to find
happiness I want to find somebody
that'll make me happy
well you can't search for happiness it's
one thing I learned happiness and I'm
quoting Julia Sweeney now that's what
she said in the movie happiness is a
byproduct of having a purpose in order
to get happiness you need to have a
reason for being now how do you find
your purpose how do you find your reason
for being well a lot of people feel like
when I've talked to them there's some
they're searching for some big complex
answer that explains everything but the
answer what I found is so simple that's
why it's hard to see and one thing AHA
said when in one of his seminar is a
woman stood up and said I don't know
where to find my purpose I don't know
where to look and he said I hate to be
the one to break it to you but your
purpose is that person right next to you
on your left and that person on your
right that's your purpose we're we're
social creatures and we find our purpose
and thus our happiness in our social
interactions with friends and family did
you find that some types of people
tended
be happier than others I interviewed a
guy at Harvard his name is Daniel
Gilbert he's a professor of psychology
and he wrote a book called stumbling
unhappiness and he studied happiness for
years and one of the questions that came
up he told me is who was happier in life
and what the studies showed was that
we're all pretty equally happy in jail
on average no matter who you if you
compare it to someone who is disabled
versus someone who's not people have an
equal capacity for happiness did you
find more more or less happiness
religious people versus atheists yes
there is there've been studies done on
that and what they have found is that
religious people tend to be a little bit
happier than non-religious people but
that also has to do with having a social
group that you're a part of that's what
brings you happiness is having a group
of people that you're a part of who want
to know about you listen to you talk to
you care about what you're doing and you
spoke with the prominent atheist Richard
Dawkins what did he have to say Richard
Dawkins is he's one of the best
interviews you can do because he's
everything he says is quotable because
he's definitive he will tell you what he
thinks and with unequivocably and he's
he's the Pope of atheists it's been
roughly a decade since Trekkies how has
the the film market changed since then
the indie film market is continually
changing because now it's what's gotten
much worse and much better for in
different ways it's much harder to
release a film through the traditional
methods because most of the distribution
companies have been bought up by
corporations and so they're all swinging
for the fence with blockbusters they're
much less interested in a nice clean
single there's a few companies left that
are still doing that and new ones come
and go but it's not like it used to be
however you can now put your movie on
YouTube and so many other internet
avenues that you can bypass those
traditional methods of release short
films now there are people making a lot
of money on the internet making short
films
and putting it on YouTube or whatever
and and making money off the advertising
that's their job and everybody says you
know well you've got to harness that new
media stuff and it sounds like a just a
platitude but you seem to have done some
pretty creative things in that regard
that I assume are actually working can
you talk about that and how our viewers
can can see what you've done
well part of releasing a film is you've
got to put little pieces out there get
people interested get them a little bit
pregnant in in wanting to see your film
so we've been putting out webisodes
outtakes excerpts special pieces of
footage that I found in the raw footage
and publishing those on the internet and
on our website which is the nature of
existence calm what's the the status of
your film network and people see it it's
done the festival circuit already yeah
we do your film festivals won some
awards and now it's being released
theatrically in movie theaters our
website will list all of the show times
and locations and then home video of
course home video will be it's still
evolving but what we're planning to do
with home video is released the
documentary on DVD as well as we're
creating a seven disc companion set of
all these topics in much greater depth
and detail for those who really want to
probe more deeply on the nature of
existence where it is there an afterlife
where is it located what is the soul
what is sin and sexuality you know is it
is it a sin to masturbate is
homosexuality a choice or is it innate
and people love the sex topics of course
there's a whole disc on that and
morality you know what is morality is it
are we born altruistic or is it a choice
or is it something we learn so all these
questions will be probed much more
deeply on those discs you must have had
some really gnarly existential crisis to
want to do this in the first place how
has it changed you it does it change
your day to day life
teachers love this part because it all
comes back to learning keep challenging
yourself your whole life
retirement is
supid why would anyone want to retire I
mean I understand not wanting to work at
a job you hate but if you're spending
your life doing something you like why
would you ever want to stop doing that
because once you once you leave the
stage
you know once the journey is over you're
done you know once you stop learning you
start dying so you need to keep
challenging yourself your whole life
finding things to do that interest you
if you're doing something that doesn't
inspire you you will burn out so you
need to be inspired in life so what
inspires you that's what you should be
doing and ideally if you can combine
that with your your job then you're
you're gonna find much greater happiness
in everyday you know day-to-day living
so find your inspiration do that never
stop until the day you die